all the time
[Music]
northern california
far from the hypodermic needles and
human fecal matter of san francisco lies
a majestic redwood forest untouched by
civilized man it is here that people
travel the world over hoping to catch a
glimpse
of the elusive sasquatch
known by many names across the globe
yeti wendigo
here we know him simply as bigfoot
why that's a curious racket perhaps he
got into a beehive
maybe he got his hands on some of that
methamphetamine on which the locals are
so keen
who's that dapper man is that general
eisenhower
no
it's bigfoot himself
he found the manscaped lawn mower that's
right the lawnmower groomer from
manscape it features a premium 7000 rpm
motor with quiet stroke technology it's
also waterproof from the future and can
take on your toughest coarsest hair
especially where it matters most like
those sensitive unmentionable areas
tell me handsome friend you think that
contraption could shave one of those san
francisco beatnik grodds
well it just shaved an entire sasquatch
didn't it
oh
bigfoot
that's for another day my friend
for another
[Music]
day june 18th pikes peak center colorado
springs colorado prepares
for the funniest
show
on earth
look i just
i just don't understand why you gave the
money back after you shot the clerk
what was the point well this look
i know this is new to you a little bit
and i appreciate that you know you're
now more conscientious but this is a con
you know i've been conservative my whole
life it's it's not conservative yeah
it's about fiscal responsibility it's a
free kill no you wouldn't understand
it's a thrill kill
you don't even have money you left the
money there that's half throat could
have fiscal responsibility let's just
split the difference you yelled i know
you
well that was just for show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that's and i got something for you sid
boy it couldn't have come at a better
time could it really we've been sitting
on something
not like not like satan with attack no
no no
that you know it's a fetish does satan
have a staple sponsorship he couldn't
get to belgium so
uh i was just about to say a french word
we had used to have like bureau and i'm
like what's the english what's the
english store with it anyway
the point is beto o'rourke sucks beto
francis o'rourke we've been sitting on
something for a while we have an on
location package here with our team
later in the uh program where we went
down uh sent i couldn't go because i had
my face on a wanted poster but uh sent
our team down there for one of his town
halls and we were saying well when
should we release this
you know because i don't want a torpedo
his political career but
and
he'll do that himself yeah then then
exactly then that happened
after the show yesterday yeah and we
were saying that we were in the we were
out there in the uh i don't know what
you call a control room maybe we're
saying it's an open floor plan and we
were sitting there going i can't believe
this is happening
so that i was like that's perfect i
think that's beto o'rourke it'll be like
when we drop the taking back sunday
parody of elon omar you know um banging
her brother
if like the marriage certificate makes
it makes its way into the public eye
this is the perfect time to release it
we have things that we're sitting on
that we haven't released yet just gotta
wait for your moment yeah yeah he wrote
the show for us yeah
thanks beto thank you francisco
and look i'm i'm
spanishifying his name it's morsi it's
chris francis yeah
francis it is francis o'rourke it's
francis o'rourke very very very mexican
have you tried the enchilada francis
style oh
yeah get a francis style what does that
mean it's a cheese whiz and not spicy
yes very bland so
idiot
yes
he's the kind of guy who shows up to a
party and brings a pinata but it's empty
makes the kids all sad
man
oh what a bummer so
we'll be talking my question to you is
uh do you think that beto o'rourke has
ruined his
political career i can't imagine this is
going to reflect well on him and and
what is it that you remember most about
beto o'rourke i say that as though you
know we've already buried the proverbial
the the figurative political yeah
the body of his political career
uh and today what are we going to be
today's about leaks
dave you already went to the restroom
right uh yes okay different leagues
we're still leaking so remember all the
uyghur camps that we've talked about in
china yeah that don't exist kind of a
reason for why you should own ar-15s uh
they exist and they're worse than we
thought and then there's also more
information on the donald trump fake you
know the russia probe uh i don't know
when sedition applies but i read up the
definition of sedition and um
i mean it's this
it's the definition so we have that the
package with mr o'rourke before we get
to that oh i should tell you guys of
course monday through thursday you can
just go to rumble or you can go to lot
of crowd.com if we are not here on
youtube because god only knows how long
we'll be here
and uh we are not doing a show on
memorial day just to let you know gerald
a how are you sir i'm better today yeah
a little bit better a little bit better
just a little bit yeah looked at beto
make a complete clown of himself again
yes how are you well i'm looking for i
didn't get to see the whole thing
because i was working and you guys said
don't watch it all because we want you
to watch the show we wanted to see your
reaction so i'm hoping it lifts my
spirits listen to ted cruz's response to
him yeah very dismissive when you're
being despaired like an irish hand of
o'rourke yes
like i've been like i've been kissed by
an angel
named francis if the angel is super gay
and annoying look if a works not spanish
i just don't know
i don't know what it is i don't know
what's true anymore i mean up is down
donna's up go irish
it's almost like i button like only the
bottom button on my shirt
what does that do
bottom
it's like i'm a big sail at that point
i'm trying to make this a thing bro it's
not working
very drafty keep trying better so uh you
hear me them quickest wit in the west
and i am going to be with him in
colorado springs you can go live with
chronic home slash tour we have the uh
the daytime show there are still some
tickets there the evening show is sold
out june 18th in colorado springs dave
landau how are you sir ahoy good how
about you i'm you know good yeah we'll
see what happens with beto yeah you'll
be better
yeah very soon okay
so uh well this is the watch and react
here right off the top um we had the
conference uh uh well we we okay we
governor greg abbott had his conference
i say because you know it's it's there
is a little bit of a i hate to do the us
versus them
but when it's a republican in a
wheelchair
i take him on our team take him under
the wing yeah yeah yeah because he fits
[Laughter]
stop it
stop it he does he there's nothing funny
the man's half shopping cart now
yeah that's why beto picks on him and by
the way also i should preface the
context before you watch this clip beto
crashes a press conference of governor
abbott the worst part is you didn't see
it but he also stole his parking space
oh i said yeah it's unreal
he parked right up next to him yeah so
he couldn't even open the van right and
he double parked it he always next to
the
expectant transgender mothers spot as
well yeah no respect he's a fraud um
doesn't practice what he preached
preaches
so uh governor greg abbott was
addressing the shooting that had taken
place tragedy obviously we addressed
this yesterday i recommend you go watch
the show because we addressed some of
the myths that were then perpetuated
immediately after the show
ad nauseum and uh he was there and it
was confusing because cnn the chiron
said protester shows up and then we said
wait there's a beto behind that
protester turns out the crazy person
who's the protester was beto o'rourke
crashing governor abbott's town hall
of course something something something
how many lives lost
let's watch excuse me excuse me
excuse me
[Laughter]
this guy gets fiery oh yeah sure you're
all alive
sir you are alive there's one more guy
though that i love you are alive if i
had a rubber hose listen
i can't believe you're a sick son of a
[ __ ] that would come to a deal like
this to make a political issue
that's texas baby he's right though yeah
can't believe he was a sick zombie
remember when uh i said get ready for
the political grand standing yeah well
there you go and he did it he decided to
pick on a guy who can't stand
he's literally only able to play 24
hours later yeah the most grandstandish
way possible we want to find common
ground let me crash your press
conference in a way that i know i can't
be productive because i don't have a
microphone just for a pr stunt because
i've failed in every political bid
pretty much ever yeah well you know this
is the trifecta president senate and now
governor love it you're not doing
anything yeah i mean i'm really not
doing anything yes but you're not either
you're doing the job that i want to not
do yeah
oh my gosh i should have thought this
out yeah
sit down
it's so dismissive and ted cruz isn't
necessarily the most authoritative i'm
just talking far as optics so when ted
cruz makes you look like i'm sorry a
[ __ ] bro that's really bad
well i mean this is a press conference
where they're not necessarily discussing
like how to solve this problem they're
giving you information on what's going
on what happened and they knew some more
stuff obviously we didn't know this when
we talked about it yesterday um that he
did have a handgun but they said the
arrow 15 was the only weapon that was
used only one of the rifles there was an
interaction as he was going in i think
there was somebody who was armed at the
very least somebody who wasn't armed one
of the resource managers at the school
confronted or saw him and didn't
actually confront didn't physically
engage right and then three people uh
three officers kind of chased him and
cornered him in that room and that's
when all of the things happened and by
the way also hero alert he shot his
grandmother in the face who then went to
the after being shot in the face
went to the neighbors yeah right asked
for some sugar
[Laughter]
no seriously that is a badass i mean 50
cent eat your heart out yeah
he was never face shot and still walk
next door no walk home
call the cop
you stole my car so they borrow your
phone
yeah there was a lot more you know
information going on so it's good to get
some updates on this to try to figure
out like we need to figure out how this
happened right so that we can help
prevent them no no no no they don't want
us to figure out how to happen
or francis or rook just like one of the
news outlets that was making the shooter
look more white
we were talking about that so yeah casey
was letting us know they literally all
anyway the point is they don't want you
to know how this happened the who what
when where why they want to immediately
pivot to non-solutions like we discussed
yesterday and then fact checked in real
time cnn
a texas representative went on and used
the exact arguments that we had already
addressed it is so predictable assume
that the left is going to come at you
with something new so you need to
educate yourself
but you will usually find yourself
pleasantly surprised okay
speaking of a complete lack of
self-awareness
president
president kamala harris uh
has a niece vice
president kamala respect the office
uh has a niece who un just sort of
accidentally wrecked
her aunt
and the former vice president biden
didn't really realize so of course uh
after we had the tragic shooting right
that's the everything is under that
context right now
but then immediately after that mina
harris tweeted the niece uh it's easier
to get a gun than baby formula
okay
everyone pause oh
that didn't go over how you think it
went over
guns are hard to get
baby formula is harder
[Music]
do you see what you did there you see
yeah i mean we had we did have three i
don't count the last year of president
donald trump yeah uh i don't know about
you i don't remember a huge baby formula
shortage no no ever no even when the
world was shut down we didn't have
shortages no you remember that you know
we had shortages with the entire planet
closed yeah so she thought she was
saying like ah it's so easy to get a gun
but really she was just highlighting
that it's difficult to get baby formula
we have a budding career ahead of you
yeah you really do you you may end up
being president of the united states
exactly yes please
by the way also uh ironically eats
baby food and formula yes well that's
all you can get keep down she
i don't know which one's who i don't
know which one well former vice
president when he's when he's a former
vice president when he's hungry he just
says bitty and someone comes yeah that's
like lebron james you know throwing up
similac now instead of yes exactly
that's what they're doing in the club
they're just pouring new neutrimogen
just like yeah instead of cocaine just
throwing it all over abroad guys you're
not making the point you think you are
right
why are you snorting similac powder
cause i can [ __ ]
it's it's for sensitive stomachs
get that on your head
rolled up well and i know this sounds
but it's not too far from reality
because this is now being parroted by
several people on the left who also
think this is a good point uh see
underling to mr kerr who was also an ass
yesterday and not to be outdone with the
golden state warriors a player damien
lee
uses the same point as uh auntie
harris's niece guns shouldn't be as
easily accessible like it's easier to
get a gun than baby formula right now
wrong uh
that's unbelievable and you know this
country that we live in
you're right because of biden i don't
know what are you missing 100 this guy's
a
genius him on every billboard american
party
yeah no i i think that uh i think i
understand what that future neurosurgeon
was saying
this is the dumbest people have the
largest platforms
hold your comments i know what you're
about to say
now yeah you can buy both illegally for
a lot of money yes exactly
yes you've created a criminal enterprise
around baby form yeah great job
the war on similac yeah all right so is
that about all we have to say about that
okay it's never sold by the gram until
now
[Laughter]
baby formula dealers on every corner and
they really think like think about this
we've just these are the first few
minutes of the program today
beta really thinks he got the best of a
guy in a wheelchair and then uh
kamala harris's niece thinks that she
was like i think i made my point
my work here is done and then also the
golden state warriors guys are like uh
yeah we've got them on the back foot
okay hey you guys should team up and be
an idiot yeah
that's a good one
power rangers with a megazord only with
a room temperature iq yeah poland
biden's your head going through the city
like oh wow this says you're legally
[ __ ]
keep stepping on everything okay
hey what happened to the empire state
building
so uh
let's go to this all right china
in another exam an exhibit uh 150
042 i don't know what number that is um
i don't even know if i just set a real
number 2042. two reason reason 55 let's
go with that i can't count that high
i can't ha i can't count to 20 i need i
need to be wearing sandals
um
if uh uh you need another reason to own
an ar-15 or another reason to understand
the second amendment let's go to what's
been going on here in china the uh
xinjiang the uyghur camps now there have
been files that were released so let me
be clear about this we've talked about
this in the past what is new there's a
massive leak of police files from um
xinjiang and uh it showed an actual
unprecedented amount of detail
surrounding china's use of you know what
they claimed were re-education camps for
uyghur muslims and um these were given
to the bbc earlier and then they were
just being authenticated after months so
here's here's a clip
these are the faces china never intended
us to see
from inside its system of mass
incarceration in xinjiang
the government has long denied its
running detention camps for uyghurs
insisting instead
they are vocational schools
for willing students
the photos almost 3 000 of them show the
reality of how whole swathes of uyghur
society have been swept up person by
person the oldest was 73 at the time of
her detention the youngest just 15.
slaves
so
we have
that was your takeaway
did you ever heard that no i think you
meant swaths yeah
so these have been slaves with an l i
have no idea i think you meant swabs
yeah like wiegers yeah you know what
they mean they pronounce everything
weird yeah they do i don't know what
they think they're who they think
they're they're fooling or getting away
with so let me kind of give you some
information here okay like we said this
was handed over there's a lot of new
information uh bbc it looks like they
did their due diligence they
authenticated a lot of these documents
okay
what do we see here
uh
well uh they refute the claims from the
communist chinese party that the camps
are just re-education centers it shows
clearly an armed police presence
um someone crying
trying to sit there i mean this is this
is like what pol pot did yes when he had
everybody sit down for like this was on
the cover of time magazine when he did
this when you saw the thing poking into
the back of their head yeah that same
energy
well pre-education sounds so friendly
yeah i mean the thing is even when
they're trying to hide it they just used
a word that we all know is is a word
that doesn't mean what you think it
means yeah re-education camps oh it's a
it's not that kind of camp it's a
re-education campus like that's exactly
what we think it is yeah that's what we
were saying it was right like wait what
do you say yeah you're saying it in a
bad way is there another way to say it
no no it's just it's just bad it must be
it must be
lost in translation no no it was
captured perfectly in translation so um
the reasons for the re-education here um
they were also included in the file so
let me give you some examples uh a 35
year old named yusup ismail um was
detained for quote traveling to
sensitive countries yeah detained means
put in jail
right yeah okay making sure everybody
understands it was uh six-year-old uh
is it taighul tayyir was uh detained
just because her son had strong
religious leanings meaning he uh he
didn't drink or smoke like all chinese
people ever
i think she was put in jail for like 10
years yeah yeah a lot and we have some
more examples of that too believable uh
and uh they've also here's something
else they've been expanded too so the
prisons have actually been expanded
they've been growing as a means to
control uyghurs and for people who don't
know who hear the word and say
it means chinese muslims it's a group of
muslims in china so i think we have a
set of leaked spreadsheets now that are
showing a quarter million uyghurs that's
unbelievable and we also have some
information as to why they were detained
2017 one man was jailed for 10 years
because he studied his islamic scripture
in 2010. tersen khadir was jailed for 16
years and 11 months for quote growing a
beard under the influence of religious
extremism so just to clarify this what
china did is they they basically
identified the uyghurs as part of a
problem group of of citizens and so
instead of trying to control different
the behavior of different people there
were a couple of different attacks right
that were attributed to this group they
said uyghurs in general are part of the
problem so they they classified an
entire group of people
as the problem and built camps and then
started coming up with reasons to send
them there and imprisoning them under
the guise of of
terrorism
does that sound familiar to anybody
right now hammond with his lazy
holocaust comparison
no that's not a comparison
in fairness
white supremacists are the problem in
this country they are the most
significant source of domestic terrorism
yep that's being used in the united
states but here's something else that i
think people need to understand uh
there's a subtext here in the chinese
government completely wrong let's be
very very clear here and i'm going to
get into more condemnation of the
communist chinese government but it also
shows that they do recognize something
that a lot of people in the west dare
not speak
that islam and it doesn't mean that
these people were guilty of any of it
but islam itself is as much of a
political prescription as it is a
religion and when you have a communist
chinese government they of course cannot
allow that uh no they recognize that
because there is no we you know we argue
about melting pot versus a mosaic there
it's you fall online period and so they
see islam as a political threat not just
you know this idea of a sort of a
theology so but even then you know
bibles are a problem over there uh so my
point is they get it all wrong now
another thing the leaked documents also
show that the government um were very
clearly involved because i've been
trying to play ignorant kind of like
with kovid
look the lesson here is don't trust the
communist chinese government period
if you care about chinese people the
chinese citizens
you really have to hope for the worst
for the ccp so as secretary and ching
chiang
we have some quotes here called for
officials to shoot anyone attempting to
escape
um they ordered increased capacity at
the center so these these well they've
been telling us that it's not
that it's non-existent and well we have
been signing deals left and right that
involve china as though they are some
kind of trade partner on equal footing
they are committing gross atrocities of
human rights well we [ __ ] about uh
atrocities of human rights committed
here in america centuries ago hey look
the world is still an ugly place
leftists
you can do something now
yeah well i know we're going to see
steve kerr come out and say that we have
to do something about this right yeah
like he's going to have the same kind of
like fervent behavior like angry
frustrated because the nba is not
beholden to china for anything right i
know i know we're going to see movie
studios come out now and stop making
movies directly related to what china
wants because of this right i know that
we're going to see disney start pulling
out apples start pulling out nike start
pulling out of china right because of
this yeah if you can save one life guys
right if you can save one life we're
talking about a quarter million this is
going on in china right now
it's uh
i mean i i i i it's it's a at best
slavery yeah
at worst who knows how far it goes a
modern holocaust
at best it's forced indentured servitude
because these people are in work camps
also effectively and at worst god only
knows how many of these people have been
killed yeah we don't have the numbers
and guess why we can't get them i don't
know if you know this the ccp is not
necessarily known for transparency folks
so probably worse now so we got all this
information from hacks conducted prior
to 2018 that's when they upgraded their
security software and had they i don't
know that we've been able to hack not we
but whoever did it has been able to hack
and get any more information so this is
this is somewhat old information it
could be far far worse it could be far
worse right yeah i can't imagine it got
better
i can't imagine that in 2019 or 2020
you're like oh my god
egg on my face you're free well and one
of the one of the things that i read in
there that said somebody wasn't using
their phone enough so they were
obviously trying to evade detection and
so they took him to jail for that yeah
not even kidding like you can't even
make this stuff up well they took him to
jail for using cricket
that's true it was
he wasn't getting any reception no it
was a grinder that's a guy who's four
cells away
i'm over here
you can just hear him at night like
hey
who wants to be bottom it don't matter i
don't fear it anyway i'm
my soul is dead
so look pray for the uyghurs there in in
china and not only them but all the
people who are under the thumb of
chinese oppression and uh by the way
don't you love it how they the left
claims that authoritarianism is
something that's extreme right
look at it today where is the where does
authoritarianism exist
when we passed the assault weapons ban
mass shootings went down
when the law expired mass shootings
tripled wrong
the idea that an 18 year old kid
can walk into a gun store and buy two
assault weapons
it's just wrong everything that guy just
says [ __ ] in god's name do you need
a solvent for except to kill someone
uh hold on a second let's change one
thing that 18 year old boy is a wigger
yep and the government's rounding him up
to put him in a
work camp where he may or may not get
out alive
hey look this is one thing that again
we've always said like you know it's the
old it's a lazy sort of trope but
correlation is not equal causation okay
good i took humanities as well but in
this case every single dictator
authoritarian
has had to disarm their population
it's not
i would prefer it if i'm an evil
dictator it's a necessity
now it doesn't mean that that's always
going to happen when you disarm your
population but you have to disarm them
if you want to subjugate them so let's
just change an 18 year old does never
need a
here's a case hey do the 18 year olds in
ukraine need rifles
because we just sent 40 billion dollars
to them to buy them
just a little i'm a little murky on the
rule book than me
hey but on the rulebook of uh grooming
no murky
it's not murky at all i thought you're
gonna put kevin's space manscaped you
saw that little bigfoot turns out
bigfoot's just a guy i know right he
just needed a shave so uh check out the
uh manscape it's the new the lawnmower
it's 4.0 i don't know they have like
three point there's always a number
attached to it but uh it's just it just
works you just shave yourself with it
but i told you with the surgery i had to
use the clippers yeah and i used one of
these and it actually really works
here's what i will say they have me like
with the things that they want me to say
the light on this thing makes a big
difference it does there's a light on
the razor and i have cut myself in many
unsavory places without it it helps me
reach areas that are a bit tainted i yep
yep i wouldn't understand that your soul
so you get twenty percent off plus uh
free shipping if you go to i'm saying
you get twenty percent office free
shipping if you go to manscape.com with
the promo code crowder20 and uh you know
they have the balls to sponsor this show
yeah see that's true now
let's go to trump russia because we have
to get back to beto o'rourke which i'm
just literally really looking forward to
yeah he's a great guy so this is one of
those things where you hear about it and
your eyes glaze over i feel this way too
okay
so i'm gonna try and make it so that
that's not the case forgive me if i fail
we all know about russiagate this stuff
that's been going on donald trump russia
russia okay uh
it's lies it's all it's all bullcrap we
kind of all know that now now what
matters is the new information that we
have the only thing that's really
changed is
um
how far along the trail
did
those in positions of power in the
institutions which you must trust
know that it was [ __ ] now we have
answers it was immediately hmm
so
uh and the truck
yeah yeah that's really kind of what's
new and then i'll give you a bit of a
refresher a little bit of remedial so uh
you know the former hillary clinton
campaign lawyer it's michael sussman
right a trial continued this week
now um
here's the thing you may not all
remember this but sussman
lied allegedly about his official
connection with the clinton campaign to
the fbi
aaron sussman is charged with a single
count of making false statements to the
fbi during a september 2016 meeting with
the bureau's general counsel the meeting
was about a theory since disproven
suggesting ties between a kremlin-linked
bank and a computer server at the trump
organization sussman told fbi director
general counsel sorry james baker he
wasn't passing the material along at the
behest of any client but prosecutors say
that was a lie and that sussman was in
fact acting on behalf of a tech
executive as well as hillary clinton's
presidential campaign in opening
arguments today prosecutor britain shaw
said
was involved in what she called a plan
to create an october surprise on the eve
of the presidential election a plan that
used and manipulated the fbi all right
okay
uh so here's the thing the fbi uh
admitted
that the investigation uh into the
allegations from sussman so sussman is
one making these allegations about trump
and russia okay the fbi admitted that
they knew it was bull crap that it was a
waste of time was there equal but they
went ahead anyway
oh so let me be clear about this this
means that um this is something we've
known for a while so let me sort of
string together the timeline the claims
that they made and the truth all
references available at lyderworth
crowder.com so that you can kind of make
sense of it because a lot of people
understand okay donald trump russia and
this is what happens they bombard you
for so long and i i this even happens to
me where you get bored you go all right
but then you forget that it's all based
on a lie because you assume that maybe
it's a half truth and a half truth and
he said she said nope
none of it's true all right
so let's go back here now that we know
when it started the fbi knew this yeah
the information that we already had is
is more illuminating let me just a waste
of time
but a fun exercise is the exact exact
fbi said it's a waste of time but a fun
exercise really you're supposed to be
having fun what are you you guys too
busy you're watching kitty porn over
there to actually do some real work why
do you doubt your institutions gerald
they're there for your protection you're
right i don't want to go to a camp all
right sorry yes exactly you're the best
it's a fun camp yeah no it's not it's
re-education go face mecca so
um the claim that they made and again i
want to set the context they made these
claims knowing that it was false at the
time that's huge as far as changing the
understanding of it so i i thought if we
re visited it and you knowing oh they
said this when they knew it was a lie
okay so the first claim that they had
they said that the uh uh of steele
dossier if you don't remember that
i'll get to it really quickly that it it
was proof that trump colluded with the
russians
okay here is the truth
the entire dossier was prepared by
christopher steele you've heard that
name fusion gps was the company he
worked with it was financed by the
clinton campaign
just to be clear now something else that
also adds some context that matters i
want to make sure i get this name right
igor denchenko the main source for the
steele dossier uh
he was given this information so the
steele dossier was given this
information from a pr executive for the
clinton campaign ah trustworthy
individual yes so basically the bulk for
all of these sources these claims this
information that the fbi knew was false
was coming from the clinton campaign
there's no doubt about that now
the only thing that changes the fbi knew
it was they were like oh yeah we know
that we know that
that's awesome like you didn't need to
depose me what are you asking me what is
it [ __ ] it's [ __ ] good can i go
get lunch well and and sussman came out
and actually said that hillary clinton
knew of course she did i mean like
there's usually plausible deniability
right no there's no possibility
that you can be like oh i had no idea
when we all know you did but he actually
testified like yeah she hillary clinton
knew exactly and then she just tweeted
out oh my gosh she's he's colluding with
russia knowing that that was a lie right
is that a crime well actually it's we're
gonna get to that sedition in a second
uh but you're right
you're right you're absolutely right
he's got like probably a month left who
chills up now the suspension
has been looking real depressed lately
yeah yeah yeah he might accidentally
hang himself in his cell he also does
not look like the kind of man who's
handy enough to fix his own brakes looks
like he might run terrified through the
woods and shoot himself three times in
the back right or a tree fall on him
[Laughter]
just clinton like clinton standing
behind the tree i didn't yell timber so
here's another claim that they made all
real things
and it was a claim but the media carried
their claim without carrying donald
trump's original claim donald trump said
hey they're spying on me and the media
fact checked it and said there was no
spying on donald trump or his campaign
right that's what they said they labeled
it a conspiracy theory oh you go to
overlay there tried to make him sound
crazy yeah
well here's the thing the truth
that we now know the fbi did spy on
donald trump and again the warrants that
they procured to spy on donald trump
were based on the aforementioned lies
that we just told you about and the fbi
knew were lies
this is so much worse remember in every
single cop movie or show it used to be
like hey can we come in you got a
warrant [ __ ]
thwart it again
you know whereas now there's like we'll
just make one up why do we always keep
coming these places without a warrant
without a warrant we just say that and
we leave well why don't we just like a
stock placeholder warrant that we can
just bring to place to place it's like
why every undercover thing here are you
a cop you have to tell me if you are i
gotta blow my cover oh jeez so danny
brosco then yeah yeah i'm a cop huh and
he kills him you're like oh jeez they're
probably gonna kill you so you might
want to put all your jewelry back in
that case and give us a good ending
montage
so here's another truth there uh the fbi
they weren't the only ones spying on
donald trump we know this now the
clinton campaign spied on donald trump
even though they're still denying this
and here's one of the quotes from them
trump and fox are desperately spinning
up a fake scandal to distract from his
real ones so it's a day that ends in why
the mor that means like hey it's every
day that's oh really they're trying to
say yeah yeah she's clever they're
clever like that says the more history
is your husband has sex with people that
aren't her yes or somebody that had dirt
on them died yeah
the more his misdeeds are exposed the
more they lie now it's not that they're
denying that the clinton and clinton
campaign is denying it think about this
think of just the few steps that we are
in now the fbi knew it was false went
ahead with warrants anyway the clintons
verifiably spied on donald trump
but they knew the media was going to
fact fact check donald trump it's the
lack of any fearing of accountability
yeah
it's just the lying so boldly in public
like ah that didn't happen he's uh
corrupt and the media goes oh yeah
they didn't happen he's corrupt and
russia oh russia
and then donald trump comes out and
they're spying on me oh he's crazy come
on donald trump nobody's spying on you
uh we have a february 2022 filing stated
that sussman worked in conjunction with
a tech executive to spy on trump oh okay
oh all right
so we have overlay here you can bring it
up there kevin a gun internet the
internet data was exploited and then
we have an ellipses i think redacted
internet traffic pertaining to trump
tower donald trump central west
apartment building and the executive
office of the president of the united
states what yep yep so while he was
president they were still spying on them
totally normal they have mics in the
room already they just wanted to try and
drive him nuts and then gaslight him or
he'd pick up the phone and hear scratch
like hello
spying
no
there you are who's no i'm not who said
that nobody you're not nobody
i've met him
i sounded nothing like him
so look we know this it's verified but
again the context is the fbi knew this
from the beginning
that you know something i've always said
don't attribute to malice but you know
you can simply be chalked up to
ignorance no this is malice yeah
definitely yeah malice of forethought
here from an institution you must trust
you're the villain if you don't trust
the fbi by the way the only people who
should have guns should be uh the three
letter agencies and your local police by
the way defund the police
so yeah you know the police are corrupt
but we'll tell you but then you should
trust them you should also just trust
the police and the fbi and the cia they
should be the only ones with guns the
point is give us all your power
uh here's another claim that was made
about donald trump and the russia
scandal okay you guys remember this the
infamous p tape okay stupid
and this was uh as late as 2021 uh
christopher steele was still claiming
that the p tape which was showing donald
trump they claimed you know with russian
prostitutes they were still claiming
that it existed that's in 2021 just to
give you context so lazy that's after
the pandemic started
like what is the
what is the reasoning behind doing that
like hey guys uh we'll do a pee tape
yeah yeah the most outlandish thing no
it seems like that should be pretty easy
to prove
yeah yeah it just takes a tape yeah it
just takes the take oh yeah yeah when
you consider the amount of investigative
work they do to try and disprove james
o'keefe you would just think that okay
they have some proof because they're
going around well but here's the truth
is uh the p tape
never happened there's there's been no
proof of it whatsoever it's never been
substantiated and a matter of fact the
the source of the allocation
that again igor denchenko was arrested
and charged with making false statements
to the fbi who already have showed that
they are okay with false statements
very soon is there a fun exercise
like i'm sorry sir it's illegal to make
false statements but i saw that guy make
it yeah but those were fun yeah hey i
got an idea we can make those statements
sir yes
let's claim a germaphobe likes peeing
prostitutes
yeah that's that's really going to fly
they're more likely to douse them in
sanitizer yeah
anastasia grows
you're better than that but it also
seems like something you would want done
to you if you were
into s m or shame and embarrassment he's
not that kind of guy no he's not no he
shames and embarrasses of course yes
right and also if you want proof that
the tape doesn't exist a billy bush one
got leaked from a bus right yeah
remember they're like and this is just
the beginning we have donald trump
saying the n word we have a month i'm
saying like 50 times yeah never never
seems to me you would have led with that
yeah
unbelievable instead he's just trying to
do what anybody else does impress billy
bush yes
i mean billy bush you get in there you
know that's always one-upmanship i know
you know how it is around billy yeah
it's just i mean the guy has a prisons
i see him and then afterwards i'm always
like what spell man that guy's a charmer
i can't believe i did that on billy bush
again what is it that he what hold does
he have on him i wouldn't talk to women
like that but i want billy to think i do
yeah
it's like prince is in his eyes
billy bush leaves no stone left unturned
so here's my
if the january s if people who basically
walked across the lawn on january 6 are
guilty of treason in insurrection and
sedition
uh how about falsely
i don't want to say false i'm being
redundant how about fabricating a story
yeah about the incoming and then sitting
present continuing this story about him
being corrupt with a and also being a
foreign entity accusing the sitting
president of treason by the way when you
know it's false
how about doing that to get him
impeached and trying to have a
democratically elected leader of the
free world removed from office
several times based entirely on
falsehoods that actually is textbook
sedition not showing up in face paint
right
also lying about something like this for
political benefit obviously in the past
people are like oh that's fine you make
up stories no no no you were trying to
get somebody to not be the president
united states and then you wasted public
money investigating your false claims
that you might let run right how i i
don't understand how hillary clinton is
just she's she's so good at getting away
with these things she's like a super
villain and we don't know but we know we
know yeah but we know
no problem i mean when you say we know
you mean we don't know but no that's
what i we don't know we don't know but
we don't know now you know but you don't
know we don't know the more you know you
know
but you don't know
i just don't want to the point is okay
look we're all trying to balance telling
you the truth with not wanting to die
see what we're doing that seems fair
yeah we're stuck between a rock and a
clinton place yes
we're stuck between little rock
and a hard place
i feel bill's just trying not to be
murdered yeah
he's just keeping it in the relationship
he's like i'm really not doing this yeah
gosh i have two minds about bill clinton
sometimes and i'm like uh there's a
piece of crap i think then i go oh wait
he probably raped when he needed
broaddricks he was a piece of crap but i
don't really consider him what he did
with hillary
it's not the same as a husband lying to
his wife and cheating on her because
that was the arrangement or she was like
just don't get caught
so is it wrong sure but it was always a
relationship based on a political power
grab they never actually were a marriage
so it's not the same as actual
philandering anyway she has tree trunk
ankles yes she does
she fell on a governor yeah so she can
suicide people with her legs
that's just like at night
at night when she asks if you'll rub her
feet someone has to yell timber for the
[ __ ] so
legs kept me in this chair
you just go to a wheelchair i don't know
what they call wheelies anonymous what
happened to you hillary clinton's calves
oh boy what about you guys same same
another one
[Laughter]
now i know it's ad hominem but you know
what she tried to unseat a
democratically elected president and
still denies the lies and had people
killed so i'm okay with you know
flicking a jab out there a little bit
yeah i mean she has a thick skin a very
thick skin and she should be able to
take it now
i'm very excited for this this is
something so on you know these packages
take a long time to put together we send
people on location i used to do all of
them but now i can't because i just get
kicked out yeah uh because i know who i
am i will go in and i'm undercover they
say no you're not i said well how did
you recognize me and they point to the
poster they go is that you i'm like
shoot ah dang it it doesn't really work
no it doesn't really work but you know
and we don't necessarily have jim henson
on the payroll so it's tough for me to
get the disguise but we did send uh he
did he'd be wasting money because he's
dead
well he has a son something i don't know
oh he does have a son yeah i'm just
puppets yeah whoever that pedophile does
the elmo thing my point is yes i can't
afford the wardrobe and makeup
happy
does it make you feel
does it make you do you feel good about
yourself you feel good making me feel
small dave i was trying to make you feel
small oh okay you do i was trying to get
you to stop wasting your money writing
checks to jim henson right well
it's not the alive jim henson and
there's a guy getting them and cashing
them well dave shut up you're ruining my
paycheck
you going to the bank is just you're all
dressed
[Laughter]
all right yes i'm jim henson
i get that all the time
please catch this
[Laughter]
in a liquor store dressed as a puppet
the dark crystal now
um so let me just remind you in case
you'd forgotten about this because now
we went through the uyghurs well man we
covered a lot of ground and they hold
the fbi lying about donald trump and
russia so in case you had forgotten let
me just refresh your memory of peter
o'rourke being a really really crappy
representation of francis's all over the
country you're out of you're out of line
and an embarrassment
[Laughter]
is right now and you're doing nothing no
he needs to get his ass out of here this
isn't the place to talk to him this is
totally predictable
sick son of a [ __ ] that would come to a
deal like this to make a political issue
yeah yeah you know it's like the left
just can't not trip over themselves
where
at this point you would think they'd
have as much sort of political clout
sympathy from people across the country
and they always push a little too far
and so people just watching going well i
kind of was going to support you but
you're such a dick yeah
so it's pretty clear that beto francis
is getting
he's getting really desperate yeah and
uh here's the thing i also want to see
the world through the eyes of you know
worthy adversaries political opposition
people who see the world differently
than i do i wanted to know more about
his um
granted failing campaign
i couldn't go so
my team went down a team of wonderful
people here to uh livingston texas to
check out one of beto's town halls beto
your presidential run was nice while it
lasted and so was this one now the
governor run all your runs but i'm
pretty sure this one's going to come to
an end enjoy another election season is
upon us and that can mean only one thing
i'm running for governor and i want to
tell you why the return of the most
radical skateboard dude in the known
universe
beto francis now after a failed run at
the senate and the presidency beto is
now setting his sights on becoming the
next governor of texas hell yes we're
going to take your ar-15 your ak-47 and
what better way to gin up enthusiasm
then to head to
livingston
[Music]
now here's where i should say i have
nothing against livingston
it's a nice town filled with friendly
and welcoming people
i'm sorry
i'm not racist well
i'll take that back
but
i couldn't help wonder
why vado chose to hold one of his town
halls here especially since donald trump
won the county by 54
points in 2020.
now i would have loved to investigate
this matter myself but considering that
these organizations now have my poster
up on a wall in my stead i decided to
send a team
of my finest to see what beta
and the town were all about
[Music]
now the first thing they noted about the
whole charade was the venue it was not
exactly uh huge i mean if i were to give
a generous estimate a very generous
estimate i'd place it at maybe about 110
people now what the event lacked in
attendance however
it more than made up for with the kind
of enthusiasm
which can only be found in the most
youthful among us
so
are you excited about vado
there was also a lot of electric energy
from other people
[Music]
one lovely local summed it up uh quite
succinctly uh-uh no veto ain't right of
course it's rude to show up to a party
empty-handed so my fine reporters
decided to hand out some bato themed
t-shirts to show support some t-shirts
um just go into the building and give
them at the merchandise that's great
thank you yeah of course
thank you appreciate it
and go back to their homes there
i think they were a hit
staffers weren't so
keen on the shirts being free uh while
they were trying to turn a profit with
theirs
[Music]
so you're trying to do a little bit of
capitalism up in here down was
capitalism
[Music]
like generally peter like they're beta
males you know like they're not good but
we think that's stupid so we're trying
to like subvert it turn it on tib you're
like nah beto is cool yeah and so we're
better males
[Music]
okay like just kind of turn i don't know
she got very mad yeah yeah
i don't what did she say to you
she was like what'd she say that it was
it's not it's not official but the team
wasn't just there to observe uh we
wanted them to get to the meat of vado's
policies really get to know the man
luckily for them beto couldn't resist
the pheromonal allure of barbados bears
[Music]
so
it sounds like you have such a great
plan for schools and the trajectory
there
um
but i have a question so that all that
good work doesn't go undone
um
you know obviously i want to be as
inclusive as possible but even last
night when we were at dinner somebody
offered us drugs and so i i'd like to
just hear how do you how do you thread
that needle of inclusivity being
welcoming
while also
stopping some fentanyl i don't know i'd
like to hear if you have thoughts on
that i really appreciate the question
there's probably nothing more important
than the safety and security of our
communities of our families especially
our kids and our grandkids we see under
abbott's failed leadership violent crime
going up drug trafficking going up when
we're focused on pulling stunts i can't
believe you're a sick son of a [ __ ]
that would come to a deal like this to
make a political issue and scoring
political points we take our eye
off the ball and the real problem
where it is i'll give you some examples
remember when he signed the abortion ban
this going governor you you understand
there's no exception for incest
how do we get here and like a deer
caught in the headlights he said well
we're going to eliminate britain
when i'm governor we're going to focus
on that and public safety is going to
improve in the state of texas thanks for
asking the question appreciate it
oh that was a lot of nothing quite a bit
of talking a lot of nothing let's give
it one more shot hello hello ben how you
doing very good how are you doing good
i'm reuben perez
um
we're both catholic right yes okay i'm
having an issue real fast my family i
think you're great i want them to vote
for you but they have the sticking point
with the pro-choice thing you know we're
both pro-choice they're not what do you
think i can tell them to maybe help
persuade them to vote
i don't know anyone who is pro-choice or
pro-life who
is happy with what we're doing in texas
right now ah
here we go again
[Applause]
maybe if he can bore his audience to
actual death he can guarantee their vote
the next election beto is playing 8d
chess
speaking of death beto it should be
noted that we aren't your biggest fans
no surprise but we do want you to be
safe so maybe invest in a better
security team that doesn't allow random
passers-by and camera people to walk up
directly behind you and follow you
backstage
[Music]
especially if the person in question is
a grown man with pigtails and a t-shirt
that simply reads autism
[Music]
all right that's enough what are the
good towns people of livingston texas
think of all this do you think the
personality of the candidate matters
pretty dramatically definitely more than
any issue
in my book if you can answer the
questions that are asked of you and if
you don't know the answer
at least say you know i'm not sure
that's what you trust me now
uh
obama i had three
body signs big ones okay stole off my
property yeah and i was more than
willing that's a little bit
and do what
[Music]
so are you excited about vado oh yeah
yeah
what do you think you can do for the
state
well like we were just talking about
her her son who is a lot younger
uh
was talking about well
where's his big money coming from well
they all get big money right and
i'm more concerned about where the heart
of the person is getting that money
is to begin with
[Music]
that sign's [ __ ] amazing
did you get this side what's more
important to you the
policy or the personality
well
i would say policy
i think
like freedom of speech
pro guns pro-life
we've been asking the same question to
everybody we've interviewed so i'm very
curious what your opinion is when it
comes to a political candidate which is
more important the personality or the
policies of that candidate
that's a good question i think they're
both equally important
uh you look at trump you know look what
he did in four years and i screwed with
him the entire time
because of his personality and because
of his uh
policies
you know they'd left him alone we would
have been a lot better off better off
further along than we are right now
so i'd have to say both honestly hold on
so one group cares about policies while
the other cares about personality and
feelings i am jack's complete lack of
surprise i had a question though so like
i know somebody
that is here maybe not
and they need a
procedure that's very difficult mr
abbott has made it very difficult to do
that
how what can
happen
like
i
you would be in very big trouble under
mr abbott if you want to seek out that
procedure yeah
um listen i'd be happy to take a picture
with you um and while vader francis was
understandably hesitant to answer my
team's questions credit where it's due
he was still gracious enough to take the
time for a picture
with his new beto male bros
that's right look at this picture
this happened
so remember when you think of beto for
governor
just think of this
exact picture
i'm sorry
i'm not racist
well
i'll take that back
yes i am racist
i like nascar more than i do
indianapolis cars
that's funny whoa jeez
that was hilarious i really like that i
love that um
steven had to go take an ample dumpling
gang a little dumpling drop the kids off
at the pool yes that's what they say
drop them off with the public swimming
pool um because we we all share a
bathroom anyway piss off youtube
[Music]
[Music]